SPEAKER 1: I am passionate
about machine learning,
but how do I show
that to the world?
SPEAKER 2: Have you considered
the Google Cloud Professional
ML Engineer certification?
It's basically a professional
stamp of approval.
Plus, preparing for it will
solidify your understanding
of designing, building, and
productizing your machine
learning models to solve
business challenges using
the Google Cloud ML tools.
SPEAKER 1: Tell me
more about this exam.
SPEAKER 2: It's a two-hour
multiple choice exam,
and you can take in a
dedicated testing center
or from a remote location
via online proctoring.
SPEAKER 1: This is great.
Thanks.
Any advice on where do I start?
SPEAKER 2: Yep.
There are tons of
training resources,
from sample questions
to hands-on labs
and on-demand courses.
Just check them out.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
Even better.
Let me get started right away.